et
notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc je n'ai un bayou bonjour je merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous secrétaire
nationale d'europe écologie les verts on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
pascal j'avais bien du groupe ebra
bonjour pascal le groupe evraz les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
l'actualité julien bayou c'était
évidemment la crise sanitaire et ce
variant omicron qui inquiète les mesures
se multiplient y compris en france les
vols en provenance de certains pays sont
suspendues les cas contacts même vacciné
seront mis à l' isolement est ce que le
gouvernement agit de la bonne manière
dans les bonnes proportions dans le bon
calendrier mais écoutez moi j'attends
j'attends les préconisations des agences
et des interviews autorité de santé
j'appelle chacun chacune à se faire
vacciner moi j'attends mon tour c'est à
partir de mi-décembre
et en particulier les plus vulnérables
les personnes en situation d'obésité les
plus agiles je crois qu'il ya vraiment
un enjeu de se protéger soi et protéger
l'ensemble de la population
puisque j'ai le temps je vais insister
sur le fait qu'on a toujours ce défaut
d'anticipation moi je le redis on voit
l'offre de transports en ile-de-france
qui s'est dégradée et c'est peut-être le
cas aussi dans d'autres dans d'autres
régions on sait désormais que les
transports en commun ont été un facteur
de propagation du virus aux alentours de
mai 2021 il ya une étude précise là
dessus je comprends pas qu'un an et demi
après le début de l'épidémie on en soit
encore à réclamer et bien l'organisation
de transports en commun y compris aux
heures de pointe le fait qu'on encadre
et qu'on régule le télétravail dans des
bonnes conditions sociales ou le fait
qu'on soit encore à installer ou a
demandé l'installation dans les écoles
de purificateurs d'air ou de capteur de
co2 au gouvernement oui il ya un retard
à l'allumage
c'est un peu comme pour la libération
des brevets voyez nous le réclamons avec
yannick jadot depuis depuis le début 1
c'est une bataille que nous menons au
parlement européen et à chaque fois on
me dit oui d'accord la libération des
brevets bien sûr mais comme ça mais au
moins six mois pour démarrer les
productions de lusine c'est pas
maintenant qu'il faut le faire oui mais
fait ça fait 18 mois désormais qu'on
aurait dû commencer et donc il ya une
hypocrisie complète de la part du
gouvernement là dessus et on voit bien
si nous laissons des poches de pauvreté
il ya un double jeu en fait quand les
états unis ont finalement dit oui
emmanuel macron n'a pas voulu passer
pour un ringard face à joe biden et donc
a dit oui on va le faire sauf qu'en fait
au parlement européen ça bloque et c'est
la france en particulier qui bloque
c'est ça la réalité et l'union
européenne dit qu'elle envoie des
données envoyées évidemment pour envoyer
des doses dans l'est dans d'autres pays
qui n'ont pas de vaccin l'union peine
dit qu'à l'envoi des doses des centaines
de médias des dons de dose très bien et
c'est pas suffisant mais quand vous avez
3% ou 4% de la population africaine qui
est vaccinée en fait notre stratégie
vaccinale nous savons bien aujourd'hui
qui a finalement qu'une seule santé
c'est peut-être la leçon majeure de
cette pandémie
il ya un lien entre la santé des
écosystèmes de la faune et des humains
et même entre les humains et donc si
vous avez au mexique une poche de
pauvreté pas possible au brésil ou comme
aujourd'hui en afrique du sud vous avez
une populations immunodéprimées parce
qu'il ya toujours autant de sida que
c'est finalement des variants peuvent se
développer là bas on voit bien qu'en
fait on n'est pas
étanche et c'est comme ça c'est ainsi il
ya un lien entre la santé des humains à
travers la planète et c'est pour ça que
nous réclamons anticipation évidemment
sur les transports en commun ça c'est le
local et au global cette libération des
brevets quand les grandes firmes
pharmaceutiques ont amassé plus de 30
milliards de dollars je pense qu'on peut
dire que le produit est amorti et qu'il
est temps de libérer les brevets et
permettent la production massive de mam
vaccins les génériques pour enfin
soigner le reste du monde oui des élus
socialistes comme honey galgo carole
delga ou des mères disent faisons simple
ramenant la vaccination obligatoire ça
existe déjà pour d'autres vaccins vous y
être favorables mois et jusqu ici je me
range à l'avis de la l'organisation
mondiale de la santé convaincre plutôt
que contraindre est en fait sa part d'un
point de vue très simple le vaccin est
une chance moi je n'ai pas du tout envie
que dans la tête des gens et
des plus jeunes par exemple on se dise
le vaccin c'est c'est une sanction voilà
c'est une chance nous avons la chance de
pouvoir prendre rendez-vous alors laissé
un peu embouteillée mais de pouvoir
prendre rendez vous pour une une dose
avant les fêtes pour pouvoir dans le
respect des gestes barrières retrouver
nos proches moi j'attends évidemment
avec impatience c'est une chance le
vaccin je remercie je voulais le faire
les médias qui passent leur temps à
casser les rumeurs les faits que news
qui circulent et j'appelle chacun
chacune à se renseigner voilà non il n'y
a pas je vais ont propagé à mon tour il
n'y a pas de surmortalité liée aux
vaccins bien au contraire bien au
contraire et donc on a vraiment je crois
intérêt à convaincre et chaque personne
qui a envie de voir ses proches à noël
est peut-être la meilleure ambassadrice
de cette vaccination sur le contrôle des
frontières et ce qu'il faut renforcer
son contrôle des frontières en france
est ce qu'il faut aller jusqu à les
fermer comme l'ont fait certains pays là
encore l'organisation mondiale de la
santé préconise les contrôler plutôt que
les fermetures on sait que ça peut avoir
des impacts économiques majeures je
pense à l'afrique du sud qui est déjà
quasiment isolée au niveau national
ternational et bientôt régionale puisque
l'ouganda a fermé a fermé ses vols
mais là dessus moi je prends peu l'avion
je le prends pas depuis très longtemps
mais les personnes qui le prennent pour
des raisons professionnelles me disent
qu'à fait il n'y a pas de contrôle en
fait que vous débarquez à roissy ou à
orly et qui a pas de contrôle il ya plus
de contrôles me dit on du point de vue à
tunis que du point de vue à paris orly
ou roissy et donc je crois que l'ayant
qu'encore un défaut de contrôle dans les
aéroports français oui clairement et
vous appelez le gouvernement évidemment
renforcé ses contrôles depuis un an et
demi bien sûr sur les antilles ce qui se
passe dans les antilles puisque
sébastien lecornu est donc arrivé 7 mai
on voit les tétons il était temps enfin
c'était ma question non mais dans quel
afin d'
imaginer que ces scènes terribles 1,2 de
pillage
d'empêchement des soignants d'aller se
faire soigner d'empêchement d ed des
médecins d'aller jusqu'à l'hôpital
ces vols d'armes
dans la paille raison d'attendre un peu
le retour au calme attendez si ses six
essais n'avait lu arènes à toulouse ou à
nice
c'est à dire qu'il est tout le monde
connaît la région centre tout le monde
connaît la réponse six essais n'avaient
mais attendez on a le ministre de
l'intérieur là qui fait par manu moi
l'expression son kéké à chaque fois
qu'il ya le moindre fait divers la
dernière fois il avait même confondu un
clip de rap le tournage d'un clip de rap
à grenoble avec une vraie scène de crime
le drame et on en avait fait des tonnes
et des tonnes et que je me déplace etc
etc sans pour autant annoncer quoi que
ce soit de concret puisque la mairie à
grenoble réclamer des renforts de police
nationale et là c'était combien de temps
qu'on attend que le ministre d outre-mer
se rendre sur place il faudrait donc
attendre que les choses soient réglées
pour qu'ils puissent venir comme un coq
en commun un prince non sa milice des
outre-mer on a un problème de droit
commun je crois qu'en fait danser des
régions et en particulier aux antilles
on a trop longtemps à accepter
l'inacceptable
ça a été normalisée voilà nous nous
disons il est
sur quel plan sur le poteau je ne tiens
pas d'eau potable vous avez vu cette
scène où une personne chez elle tourne
l'eau du robinet c'est de la boue qui
sort à l'eau et au chu vous devez venir
avec votre propre eau potable
c'est ça la réalité de la guadeloupe
sébastien lecornu qui se dit c'est cette
station d'épuration sur dix qui sont
hors les clous des fuites massives de
l'eau quand il ya l'eau potable
sébastien lecornu qui dit prêt à ouvrir
le débat sur l'autonomie de la
guadeloupe est qu'elle a raison d'ouvrir
c'est une folie c'est une folie enfin je
ce gouvernement vraiment sale et il y
avait et magne le maquereau qui disait
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs mais je
crois que là vraiment c'est
particulièrement dangereux
le débat sur l'autonomie gouvernement
d'amateurs mais bien sûr le débat sur
l'autonomie il est parfaitement légitime
mais encore faut-il pouvoir développer
des arguments dans un contexte serein je
me souviens qu'en 2009 avec
l'élément clé les fortes mobilisations
nationales on peut parler d'autonomie
moi je suis pour le droit à
l'autodétermination des peuples nous
sommes régionalisme sommes pour la
différenciation nous les écologistes
nous pensions que la subsidiarité ça
veut dire prendre les décisions au plus
proche de la population moi je n'ai pas
de problème particulier à une hypothèse
ni tabou
mais comment comment peut-on imaginer
qu'un ministre comme ça au détour d'une
crise joue avec l'unité de la nation
pour pourquoi pour provoquer le débat en
pleine en pleine crise s'est jouée sur
l'unité de la nation ils parlent pas
d'indépendance je trouve que c'est
vraiment vraiment enfin ccc à côte à
mille lieues de tout ce dont on a besoin
c'est à dire de services publics
d'emploi et de droit commun je le redis
les personnes aux antilles demande le
respect quand il ya le chlordécone qui à
50 ans a été autorisé de manière
dérogatoire en gros c'était dangereux
pour la métropole mais parfaitement
acceptable pour les antilles c'est ça la
réalité de ce poison
que vous avez les sols qui sont
désormais polluée pendant 700 ans que
vous avez des records de cancer de la
prostate chez les hommes
aux antilles en particules en martinique
en guadeloupe
que vous avez le gouvernement est encore
en particulier manuel macron qui a menti
qu'il était dans le déni vis-à-vis du
caractère cancérigène du chlordécone
c'était encore il ya deux ans et que la
population réclament la gratuité des
tests qu'on puisse enfin vérifier qui
est contaminée et qui prend des risques
dans la consommation tous les jours
nous demandons aux côtés des antilles
grant antillaise le respect et donc le
droit commun la même égalité d'accès aux
services publics à la santé à l'eau
potable à la mobilité universitaire la
lutte enfin contre la vie chère il ya
moins de revenu en guadeloupe et des
prix de base produits de première
nécessité en particulier serviettes
hygiéniques beaucoup plus cher comment
voulez vous comment voulez vous qu'un
débat serein puisse se lancer sur
l'autonomie oui je vais moi j'y vois une
profonde marque de diversion et qu'un
gouvernement puisse comme ça engagé un
sujet aussi majeur de d'institutions
débat encore une fois parfaitement
légitime je le comprends pas voilà il ya
une demande de respect il est pas là on
va parler d'un autre sujet d'actualité
c'est la crise migratoire puisque après
la mort de 27 migrants mercredi soir au
large de calais une réunion s'est tenue
hier justement à quel l initiative de
gérald darmanin sa cible les passeurs il
veut des mesures plus sévères et un
avion européen de frontex sera déployé
au 1er décembre pour mieux localiser ces
passeurs vous approuver ces mesures là
encore hypocrisie parce qu'il n'y aurait
pas de passeurs s'il y avait deux voix
sur pour l'angleterre est donc cette
situation catastrophique
dans le nord pas de calais elle dure
depuis très longtemps il y avait un
ancien président de nicolas sarkozy qui
parlait de la jungle de calais qui
soi-disant en
déplaçant les tentes avait réglé le
problème la seule manière c'est la seule
manière obscure est sûre c'est
d'organiser l'accueil d'abord cessons de
dire que cette immigration menace notre
pays ensuite regardons les choses telles
qu'elles sont la personne le maire
écologiste de grande synthe damien
carême avait organisé l'accueil un camp
d'accueil avec médecins sans frontières
et la régulation et la populace ils
veulent aller en angleterre et banals
par an facilitons facilitant leur le
passage d'où il faut revoir la courbe de
tous qu'il faut dénoncer l'accord du
touquet pourquoi
frontières britanniques à l'accord du
tout en fait il ya les fasting président
sedan les anglais comptent sur nous pour
empêcher les gens de passer et nous
comptons sur l'italie pour empêcher les
gens de venir en france et maintenant
nous payons la turquie pour qu'elle
garde les migrants et donc nous
pactisant avec un dictateur appelons la
comme ça appelons le comme ça erdogan
qui est en train de massacrer les
institutions et le la liberté
d'association ou de réunions dans dans
la turquie nous pactisant avec ces
dictatures ou quasi dictature européenne
nous patinons l'un d'eux mêmes sur la
france
tout ça pour éviter à quelques
malheureux de trouver refuge on va
envoyer au panthéon joséphine baker qui
est arrivée en france par par bateau
nous célébrons la richesse de ce qu'elle
peut apporter demain et aujourd'hui ces
personnes qui fuient la misère ou la
guerre concrètement comment on fait la
voix sûre c'est qu'il faut dénoncer il
faut commencer par dénoncer alors il
faut commencer par organiser l'accueil
donc moi j'en veux à ce ministre garde
des sceaux dupond moretti qui nie la
réalité du traitement infligé aux
migrants par nos forces de l'ordre c'est
un arrêté préfectoral a bien on le redit
ces migrants ils veulent aller en
angleterre comme enjeu le pas rester en
france c'est sûr mais quand ils sont en
france on peut commencer par leur
distribuer l'alimentation dont ils ont
besoin la réalité parce que je vais à
calais quand même beaucoup de wenzhou ça
n'occupe il ya un arrêté préfectoral
depuis le 10 septembre 2020 qui est
interdit en certains points la
distribution alimentaire c'est ça la
réalité - le pays et comment on fait sur
les accords du touquet voilà ça prend du
temps ça prend des mois ça prend
quasiment deux ans de les dénoncer ces
accords du touquet est ce qu'on fait
comme le dit xavier bertrand et bien
tant pis
on se débrouille on dit non les rejeter
temps faut les dénoncer mais bien sûr
qu'il faut les deux oui on a déjà
abandonné c'est sur un tout autre sujet
mais on a déjà abandonné les petits
pêcheurs artisans face aux volontés de
l'angleterre de les empêcher d'aller
dans l'est dans les eaux poissonneuses
anglaise
ça n'a absolument rien à voir mais je
crois qu'il est temps maintenant de
faire un peu de politique et donc vous
me dire ça procède ça prend deux ans et
ça fait 15 ans en fait que la situation
est mauvaise et moi je leur dis ça
commence par cesser de considérer
l'immigration comme un problème d'abord
puisque ces personnes veulent partir en
angleterre organisons des voix sur le
passage et si nous consacrons de
l'argent de frontex et autres ça n'est
pas pour surveiller les bateaux mais
pour les accompagner tout simplement
l'autre actualité c'est la fonderie sam
dans l'aveyron qui a été placée en
liquidation judiciaire cessation
d'activité immédiate ya quasiment 350
emplois qui sont concernés renault a
refusé de soutenir le seul projet de
reprise estimant qu'ils ne présentent
pas les garanties nécessaires et puis
renault dit qu'il ya des incertitudes
sur le marché automobile qu'on est dans
une phase de transition
est-ce que du coup c'est pas aussi une
conséquence de cette transition
écologique que vous prenez ce qui a
tendance à passagers sur que non c'est
une conséquence de l'absence d' état
stratège
je suis en lien avec les écologistes de
l'aveyron qui soutiennent la fonderie je
me rendrai prochainement un soutien nous
avons donné nous avons donné 5 milliards
d'euros à renault sans contrepartie sans
aucune contrepartie rien faites ce que
vous voulez et qu'est ce qu'ils font
c'est philippe martinez qui m'en
parlaient ils font ils distribuent des
tracts à l'intérieur de l'entreprise sur
les dix manières de quitter l'entreprise
payé 1 on vous dédommage pour partir
voilà la réalité de le quoi qu'il en
coûte rond on a donné sans contrepartie
des milliards d'euros des milliards
d'euros à une entreprise qui on avait
fait déjà le coup en 2008 en 2008
souvenez-vous crise financière on va
aider sans contrepartie les
constructeurs d'automobiles et du coup
il avait triché sur les tests diesel des
locaux lisez
la majeure partie de leur production
dans le reste de l'europe où au maghreb
est investi à fond sur les suv ah ben
bravo bel investissement donc nous nous
disons nous écologistes la transition
s'organise et ça passe par là critères
isation des aides économiques c'est ce
que martèle yannick jadot il est hors de
question c'est votre argent mon argent
l'argent du contribuable a aidé des
entreprises qui s'en sert pour créer
beaucoup plus de dividendes nous voulons
crise et les aides publiques ont avec
des contreparties sociales et notamment
l'égalité salariale femmes hommes c'est
fini ça fait 50 ans maintenant qu'on a
dit principe à travail égal salaire égal
nous voulons des résultats et bien sûr
la transition écologique social à
s'amuser la fonderie du jura il ya
bausch à rodez l'atrazine ya ce héros
pmi la chapelle darblay ya je rends puis
j'ai ajar blé le papier par exemple
quand on met plus quand on mène stop
humeau c'est qu'on détruit des emplois
là où fléchi pitié pédales et ça c'est
assez marrant parce que ça fout
les questions comme il nous fait selon
détruire l'emploi mais qui a foiré qui a
foiré jusqu'ici attendez attendez
c'était une question rhétorique je vais
vous répondre c'est pas les écologistes
parce que si nous avions eu dans
l'histoire en 2008 si nous avions été au
match est sûre en 2019 eh bien nous
aurions mis des contreparties et cette
entreprise n'aurait pas pu fermer ou au
contraire elles ont été rachetés et
soutenu parce que la contrepartie de ces
milliards d'euros que nous avons déversé
sur ces multinationales c'est de
soutenir l'emploi c'est de soutenir
l'investissement c'est d'avoir enfin la
mise en place de cette égalité salariale
dont on parle depuis noël 1972 donc ceux
qui foirent la transition écologique ce
qui donne sans contrepartie aux
entreprises ce sont ces gouvernements
parfaitement irresponsable absolument
pas stratégique qui comme ça préfère
soutenir
l'offre ou sans aucune contrepartie
il n'ya pas longtemps on a une voiture à
moins de deux litres aux cent
intéressant quand même de soutenir cette
recherche de mettre des critères à au
soutien aux constructeurs automobiles ça
a été enterré sa a été enterré par une
personne qui s'appelle emmanuel macron
on va passer à l'actualité politique et
ce qui s'est passé du côté d'europe
écologie les verts ce week-end matthieu
orphelin n'est donc plus porte-parole de
yannick jadot pourquoi qu'est ce qu'il
s'est passé mais à vous vous êtes au
courant des graves mises en cause qui
entoure nicolas qui nicolas hulot qui
concerne nicolas hulot nous nous plaçons
sans aucune ambiguïté du côté des
victimes moi je salue lors leur courage
le courage qu'il a fallu
pour parler assez assez différentes
personnes qui n'ont absolument rien à
gagner à se mettre ainsi en danger en
fait à révéler ce que nicolas hulot a pu
leur faire il en faire subir il ya il ya
des dizaines d'années nous nous placions
du côté des victimes et donc comme
matthieu orphelin et tu sais c'est pas
un secret est un proche ou était un
proche de nicolas hulot nous nous sommes
dit qu'il ne pouvait plus porter la
parole de yannick jaloux et que donc il
savait des choses et balises vous êtes
vous vous lui poserez la question moi je
lui ai demandé de me
demander il m'a dit non
tout ce dont nicolas hulot lui à lui
aurait parlé c'est
si clément doit parler comme ça c'est
des affaires d'adultères
donc entre personnes consentantes c'est
ce que vous dites c'est ce qu'il m'a dit
voilà j'imagine et c'est le rôle de la
presse qui sera mis sur le grill qui
sera interrogé
dans les prochains jours évidemment
qu'on a du mal si matthieu orphelin n'a
rien à se reprocher s'il n'a rien
couvert pourquoi lui avoir retiré le
porte parole a mais parce que nous
voulons parler de soutien à la
transition écologique nous devons parler
d'égalité salariale nous voulons parler
de soutien à l'autonomie de la jeunesse
et à chaque fois que matthieu orphelin
en tout cas dans les prochains jours et
prochaines semaines s'exprimera vous
aurez et c'est normal des médias pour
lui demander que saviez-vous quelle est
votre réaction et dites nous en plus et
c'est normal et donc pour
pouvoir continuer la campagne est aussi
pouvoir clairement assumé je le dis moi
je ne comprends pas le soutien dont a
bénéficié nicolas hulot au gouvernement
quand la sphère hebdo est sorti
peut-être que l' enquête était pas
suffisante c'était en 2001 en 2018 et
c'était une mise en cause extrêmement
grave et
il a eu un soutien en bloc en bloc de la
part de marlène schiappa du premier
ministre et du président de la
république nous nous disons nous nous
croyons que les verts personne ne savait
personne n'avait entendu parler
d'affaires autour de nicolas hulot alors
nous avions entendu parler pour être
très précis de ces donc rumeurs
d'adultère c'est un livre de bérengère
bonté qui en parlaient
kivu qui pas de deux agressions mais qui
parlait de beaucoup beaucoup d'adultère
moi je voulais pas lui mais j'ai
découvert les bonnes c'est assez
tardivement ça doit dater de 2010 et
donc ces rumeurs courraient mais
maçonnique fayette votre appel il s'est
présenté à la primaire
des écologistes sans être adhérents en
2011 et il a été battu par eva joly moi
je pourrais être très net je soutenais
eva joly
en 2017 ou 18 on n'a cessé de l'inviter
ou de s'en réclamer ou de vouloir
cautionner son action parce que il était
mis en cause lourdement dans hebdo et il
nous semblait sans que ça soit une
atteinte à la présomption d'innocence
qu' il n'était plus possible de dire
nous croyons des victimes et nous
continuions à valoriser sa parole donc
ça c'est un choix politique que nous
avons fait
s'il avait été membre d'europe écologie
verts il y aurait pu avoir des
signalements nous en place une cellule
de signes allemande enquête qui est
indépendante et toutes les informations
de meuron ne remonte pas forte
heureusement et qui nous fait des
préconisations que nous suivons mais
voilà il a fallu tout le travail de
renvoyer spéciales
et joseph et j'en profite pour saluer le
travail au long cours d'envoyé spécial
service public et je crois que c'est
parce que c'était le service public que
cette journaliste virginie villa a pu
enquêter au long cours et qui permet de
mettre à jour ces accusations nature
fait l'impasse que matthieu orphelin lui
dit que c'est plus direct c'est un
prétexte à faire vélo et que
il a été
viré de son poste de porte parole en
raison de désaccords stratégiques sur la
campagne de yannick jadot qu'est ce
qu'on va se fout là c'est faux j'ai levé
en début de semaine il était très
content donc il manque dans son
communiqué oui bah c'est de la diversion
après voilà voulu poser la question mais
il n'y a pas de problème avec la
campagne de yannick jadot ah bah non au
contraire au contraire oui certains qui
je vais vous dire à quel point je suis
fier moi au contraire que dans cette
campagne
où l'ensemble des valeurs vire par
dessus bord à quel point je suis fier
mois secrétaire national de ce parti
écologiste d'avoir une voix forte qui
rappelle le devoir d'humanisme du pays
nous avons une devise très simple
liberté égalité fraternité elle est où
la fraternité quand le préfet du pas de
calais met en place un arrêté
d'interdiction de distribution
alimentaire elle est où la fraternité
quand nos forces de l'ordre dans nos
forces de l'ordre sur ordre de la
préfecture les intérimaires de l'aca des
agents de sécurité lasserre les tentes
et donc moi je vais vous dire ça
aujourd'hui mais nous sommes fiers de
tensions internes c'est un problème par
exemple avec sandrine rousseau qui on me
présente campagne mais pour quel point
d'être place avec
vous écrivait à guillaume lacroix qui le
secrétaire national du parti radical de
gauche vous êtes d'accord sur la laïcité
lui faut réprimer ce que sandrine d'un
ruisseau est d'accord avec ça et à
l'arrêt lui comme si c'était la patronne
elle a répondu oui oui mais pourquoi
avoir besoin d'aller
c'est yannick jadot il devrait vous dira
ce que yannick jadot est d'accord c'est
l'ado points tout simplement je
comprends que enfin quel est le toit pas
la difficulté nous allons organiser une
primaire autour d'un socle
programmatique dont l'ensemble des
candidats et candidates se réclamait on
a organisé
une joute un débat sans se battre et
ensuite yannick jadot a gagné et les
différents candidats et candidates le
soutiennent voilà merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin
[Musique]